[Music]
hey everybody uh tommy back in a second
because he always has to wait till the
absolute last minute and then he's like
oh i forgot my hat then he has to like
run and go get it so you know what i
mean it's just like
this is my life we do it at the same
time every day i don't understand
but yeah
well you know
why didn't you bring it in here earlier
you were like you've been sitting here
for 10 minutes like just farting around
i don't have my hat on and then it's
like you know well i just pushed the
button to start it then he's like oh i
got my hat he's gotta like run off yeah
jesus cover up my [ __ ] shiny dome hey
you're the one i shaved it no no
[Laughter]
okay
i would say i would shave my head too if
it uh didn't look funny yeah because i'm
sick of like i'm not a [ __ ] clean hair
out of the drain too i know
tammy says i saw pookie yeah she's she's
pookling around yeah yep there she went
again
i had to do the bushes today too i got
most of them done you did the bushes
today yeah when did that happen
trim in the bushes oh i got to do that
one on the end i got to get do the time
because i was thinking you were in here
the whole time and then i was like and
then it stormed really bad this
afternoon and i was just kind of like
holy [ __ ] like is he out there like
doing bushes yeah there were the axe i
had there was all kinds of [ __ ] growing
up in the bushes that had to be cut from
the bottom of pulling that out yeah
let's look at work today man
yeah and then i got to cook cooking too
and i gotta make some tea when i get
done okay make some tea and and
heat me up and heat me up some some pita
bread so i can have some more popular
problems um looks like people may be
starting to come in i don't know we got
an announcement to make with the shirts
there's a problem with the shirts well
not like a big problem no it's just that
it'll be a delay
yeah it's probably not going to be that
big of a delay i'm just talking about
like maybe next week or something yeah
what ended up happening was that when i
ordered the uh the ink i accidentally
ordered the
acrylic screen printing die instead of
the fabric screen printing dye so it's
for paper and yeah and wood and stuff
and like i didn't notice until we
started like doing the shirts today and
we're like they're like these are funny
looking yeah this doesn't look right so
cooking it and it was bubbling and just
the color looked uneven it was like gray
and white and gray and white and i said
i'm gonna wash this shirt and see what
happens to it i washed the shirt and if
some of it fell out and i was just like
what the [ __ ] is going on
and i looked real close at the [ __ ] it
was it was for wood
ordered the wrong one the jar looks
exactly the same yeah they really should
uh it's just a little symbol on it is
different yeah because i didn't even
realize yeah well because the thing
about it was that when i went back to
amazon amazon didn't have any of the
fabric diet i had to go to blick art
materials and buy it there yeah it was a
big old jar she got two big 30 jars yeah
i think it was 30 or 35 dollars
yeah we're gonna have to find some other
[ __ ] yeah use it for
a screen print on something around here
huh yeah we can screen print on
something we'll think of something i
don't know yeah but uh and ruined five
shirts
yeah
because i mean we had some but it's like
i ordered a few more too yeah so
but yeah so they'll so the ones i know
camp guy and next dimension media like
yeah ordered a couple shirts but like i
said if we have like a little bit of
screen printing we might be able to do
three shirts with that be able to fill
some of it
yeah um we might be able to do it also
one of those shirts was um
a bee's nest shirt oh business ocp shirt
oh okay i didn't like waiting on that
yeah i did it okay i shot that before i
did the other job and it came out
looking pretty good and it washed and it
came out okay but i don't trust it over
time that'll come out yeah if that's not
the right thing yeah it's not the right
ink yeah so i'd so i already ordered
more shirts and ordered more ink and
you know it'll be here in a couple of
days so it'll be fine so you know we
just wanted to tell everybody that
he's not in a hurry yeah okay so that's
fine
yeah because i didn't even like i said
that jar looked exactly the same yeah
and when i went back amazon didn't even
have any of the fabric kind that was the
only kind that they had so just uh easy
mistake
first time we've ever run into that
problem i didn't know there was another
kind of that [ __ ] i didn't either it
didn't really honestly did not occur to
me yeah
i mean duh it's like you know it seems
obvious in hindsight but i didn't i
didn't realize that at the time
so yeah i didn't think it was two
different things
so let's talk about death machine we
brought up this movie when we were
talking about split second because i
said i think that the same guy either
the director on this or the
cinematographer or special effect or
something like that also worked on split
second
and i remembered that um
that i had heard about death machine i
don't think i'd ever seen the whole
thing before but we saw it on brandon
brandon tennold's channel yeah like he
did a show about it like years and years
ago so i kind of remembered it from that
i saw a bunch of little clips from this
movie but i thought i had seen it before
but i didn't i was thinking about gun
head
yeah i thought yeah this is better than
guns not better than gun head yeah this
is better because brandon did gun head
too
so
but i kind of remember they're similar
but not the same if you like split
second you'll like this one too this
one's more
insane
a lot more
for fanatical i guess you could say it's
pretty intense
it's got good sets
brad dorf carries the movie he's [ __ ]
crazy as [ __ ] in it
i mean you know what else is new he's
about 40 i think he's like 42 43 when he
made this movie he's got a long black
wig on he's in good shape and [ __ ] he's
probably the best he'll ever see black
brad dora he looks like a sex symbol he
looks like iggy pop jenny's like he
looks just like iggy pop he does with
that long hair
it actually kind of suits him yeah yeah
he looks really good in it and he's just
cr he plays a crazy ass hacker that's
trying to get laid from this uh she's a
reporter i guess is what she no she's
the ceo she's the cc of the company yeah
i got confused she's the ceo they
brought in there isn't a real
complicated story they're trying to find
the secret vault that a [ __ ] robot
would
came out of it's a monster movie
and uh it's a killer robot kill a robot
um
it's got good matte
effects um
good practical effects got a good
monster in it
um
it's hard to tell how they did it i
don't know if it was a puppet or if it
was [ __ ] stop motion i think it was a
puppet filmed in a way to make it look
like stop motion i think yeah because
sometimes it had a little bit of a
robocopy stop-motion vibe to it but
the guy
that worked on it
uh was kind of more known for doing
puppet kind of stuff yeah okay so
it looks big but i don't think it was i
think it was probably only a quarter
scale but it looks big or maybe it's one
third scale
it's hard to say it looks like it's
regular size it's got a pretty good
story and it's a cheap movie low budget
movie but this is the way you do a
little budget movie today they would
have trauma would have done this or
[ __ ] what was the other one that did
nazis from cynthia at the
[ __ ] asylum asylum asylum would have
done something like this but it wouldn't
have been as cool
asylum would have used a bunch of cg and
the writing wouldn't have been that good
this
this is
it's not it it's not good but it's
it's good that's the only way i can
it's entertaining well like i said just
like split second that's what i'm saying
if you liked that movie you'd probably
like this one because it's this one is
even more this movie is like so 90s that
it hurts yeah like all of [ __ ] like yeah
it's very 90s cyberpunk uh the look of
it and
uh the way the people dress and like
every they're all hackers and yeah
everybody kind of thing [ __ ] goth
industrial 90s right industrial it looks
it feels kind of japanese it's i don't
think it is but it's british actually
but there's something about it it feels
kind of like it's a japanese movie but
like it's not it's a british movie
yeah wow it's a british director okay
it's got good special effects for a
cheap movie it's got great well like i
said the guy this was actually um the
guy who directed that directed this
sorry
uh was steven norrington this was his
first movie and he went on to do uh
blade okay yeah yeah it's the guy that
did blade he also did league of
extraordinary jokes okay so let's pull
that against him but you know what i
mean he did blade uh and actually he
worked on he was more a special effects
artist before he went in direct he was
uh he did life force okay which he
worked on aliens he worked on the
witches yeah which was great okay and
hardware yeah yeah i did get an aliens
feel in the in it a lot uh yeah the sets
were like something from the aliens you
know uh up in the sulaco or down in
[ __ ] hadley's hope it did have that
look it's not quite as high budget
but it's pretty well crafted they they
they put effort into this movie
uh the edit is a little crazy uh but
that's the tone of this movie this movie
you know what it is though
the shitty thing about this um
for one thing the director's cut of the
movie i don't think has ever been
released anywhere except maybe germany
okay the actual cut of the movie was the
one we watched we watch it for free on
voodoo
um i think other places you can watch it
but you have to pay it's like 3.99 or
something
and the thing about it is that one uh 21
minutes have been cut out of it so like
the version we watched was an hour was
an hour and 39 minutes it was originally
two hours okay um because i saw i was
watching like another i think it was on
good bad flicks where he kind of went
into like some of the scenes that were
taken out okay um and also
it's been cut down to
like a square like aspect ratio like a
4-3 aspect ratio and it's not really
supposed to look like that okay so i
don't even think cause he showed um
because he said you know the the
director's cut is like really hard to
get hold of but he showed the difference
between
the square aspect ratio version and the
regular one and it wasn't so much the
editing because you could tell what was
going on in like the wider screen
because it cut off like a big
portion of either side so there's like
all this stuff going on over here and
you can't see it so the framing of it is
like really messed up like whoever did
i don't know why it was cut down like
that but why they didn't wonder why they
haven't released the director's cut on
dvd i don't know like maybe eventually
they will because i feel like this this
i mean it's not probably not as well
known as split second but this it does
have like a cult following okay you can
definitely tell it's a cult movie yeah
it's a well-made movie that
for the budget okay uh like i said they
put a lot of effort into it and it's the
acting is the acting is over the top but
it fits the tone of the movie the movie
has kind of an insane tone kind of like
something about a first robocop like
robocop one but maybe even knocked it up
a notch or two
um
yeah the the acting
quality is kind of uneven some people
are better than others yeah brad dorf is
great the leading lady's great the two
the two guys uh [ __ ] uh weyland and
yutani yeah
that's another thing that's nothing
one character's name is is [ __ ] john
carpenter yeah the other one's name is
wayland the other one's name is yutani
uh there's a sam raymond there's a sam
there's a guy named sam raimi yeah
there's a guy named oh and there's a guy
named scott ridley scott ridley is the
other guy and the the character that um
that brad dorf plays is named jack dante
who i'm assuming is supposed to be an
homage to joe dante yeah okay uh so
there's that as well yeah i forgot to
say richard brake is in this as well
like he was really really young yeah uh
but i know there's teeth anywhere yeah
if you if you know who she's talking
about that was the guy who got his head
scrunched off in
um a [ __ ]
hannibal rising and he was also he got
made the magic lsd for mandy and mandy
that was a great i mean he's been in
[ __ ] up stuff and he's young in this
and and um i almost i didn't know he was
ever that good looking that [ __ ]
when he was young very happy and he's
like crazy he's way over the top
is like super coked out
[Laughter]
but it's really entertaining like yeah
but shut the [ __ ] up he was kind of
kind of leading man handsome in this in
this era i don't know how old it was
probably 30s
yeah this was 94 though
yeah so uh it's just it's just a fun
movie uh now i want to see it i want to
see the director's cut i want to see it
in in the original aspect ratio it's a
big difference i couldn't believe it
because there's one scene the thing
about it like the the
the killer robot the titular death
machine although they don't call it a
death machine in the movie they actually
he actually calls it war beast like
orbeez um and then he has another name
for it like the morale
something i don't know morale sapping
front line or something like that but
yeah he calls it that but he mostly
calls it the war beast
i have to say that what you can see of
the death machine looks [ __ ] awesome
it's like really really cool looking
it's kind of like a an ed-209 but it's
more skeletal looking like it doesn't
have any body plates on it it's got a
movable mouth yeah it's like
it's got hands that have claws that
thick and everything can spin and chop
and it can bore its way right through a
wall a solid wall
and it can run fast and what's cool
about it is that you know how in
terminator we always saw it from the
terminator's eyes it's all infrared and
it's analyzing
well you can get to see through the eyes
of the war beast and the war beast sees
everything as a video game even with
game over and score and
you know scores and points
yeah
yeah it's pretty cool
pretty cool idea
i mean i kind of feel like this now that
music plays
video games music well you know might as
well make it fun yeah well the thing
about it i mean in the universe of the
movie the war beast death machine was
built by brad dora's character who was a
crazy person yeah he's crazy so that
seems like something that a crazy person
would do yeah now some of the stuff that
they cut out because like i said they
cut like 21 minutes out of this um they
said actually a lot of the stuff they
cut out made brad dwarf look even
crazier and more dangerous like there
was actually one scene where he uh tried
to rape the woman yeah they took that
out and uh there was some more stuff i
mean there was some other stuff too
there's like there was a whole subplot
that uh that the woman what was her name
haley
hayley hale
kaden
kaden hale and maybe something like that
hard for me to keep keep trying but
there was a whole subplot where she had
had a daughter
and the daughter had been killed
accidentally and she kind of felt
responsible for it and so there was kind
of like a weird thing where she almost
had like a mother-son relationship like
with brad dwarf's character yeah because
he was like kind of a lunatic kind of
um so there was a lunatic yeah but there
was a little bit of that um but they
took pretty much all of they took all of
that out so there was like some scenes
of her like dreaming about it and all
like the little girl it was like some
some horrible but like ridiculous like
way to get killed like getting your arm
caught in the
in the sink like thing you know what i
mean what do you what do they call that
garbage they got supposedly yeah there
you go i don't know why i couldn't think
of that but um but yeah so so yeah 20
minutes would take it wasn't all violent
stuff but that was like that whole
subplot was taken out and a lot of the
brad door of crazy was taken out
although they left plenty of it in i'm
not saying that it wasn't that but i
recognized um what is her name eli uh
poujay is it poojay or puget poo
poojet i think or yeah i don't know um i
recognized her so i looked up her
wikipedia page i guess she started out
on tv like in miami vice like in the 80s
uh a team she was on friday the 13th the
series she was in a movie called la
takedown she was in like a couple of
michael mann movies i think i recognized
her
from the 90s
reboot of dark shadows okay because as
soon as i as soon as i saw that on her
page i was like that's where i know her
from because i used to [ __ ] love that
show
like back in the 90s and yeah somebody
was talking about william hootkins who's
in this playing john carpenter
um
yeah slasher fred said he did a lot of
movies including batman from 1989 or
raiders of the lost ark yeah that's
right you called that you said he was in
raiders of the lost yeah yeah yeah
wasn't he was he porkins as well perkins
he played porcupines i think he was
porkins from star wars
yeah i think he was but yeah he played
john carpenter in this he gets uh torn
in half by the robot so there's that so
there's that but yeah i kind of feel
like
if you see like i said i'm there's
another channel called good bad flicks
and he did like a really funny
kind of like 13 14 minute uh review of
this and he showed like some clips of
the movie in its original aspect ratio
because there were a couple scenes but
especially where the death machine is
attacking
and it's like it's really fast edited
which i guess i mean it is fast edited
that happened a lot in the 90s because
they just thought that was cool as [ __ ]
back then but um
but you couldn't really tell what was
going on and i'm just like wait what the
[ __ ] is going on but when they show it
in its original aspect ratios you could
actually tell what was going on even
though it was edited quickly yeah so i
feel like it wasn't so much the fast
editing it was the fact that there was
like big chunks of action over here that
were cut off that you can't really tell
what was going on yeah hugo said he saw
a split second he says this is okay
um yeah there's just something about
these two movies
where
they're not good
yeah but they're they're there's a lot
of potential there you know what i mean
and they they put effort in them
they all had they had problems
um with little things here and there
but i should have known about them back
when they came out i would have really
okay this movie
death machine
had i seen this at 17 i loved it i
thought it was the best movie ever
you know
i mean this is kind of like a low budget
version of
alien yeah uh die hard robocop
yeah all happening and like all kind and
hackers right like all at the same time
until they tried to film this thing
where every single frame was badassery
yeah it didn't quite work but you could
imagine that it did
you don't thought about you could kind
of like yeah if it was a little bit
better shot or if it's a little bit
better quality or if it wasn't quite so
hazy and if the dialogue was a little
bit better and that was delivered a
little bit right that would have been
awesome
it almost could have been like aliens
you
know it was kind of like the movie that
you you saw after aliens you saw aliens
and you wanted more of that but you just
watched aliens to death so then you saw
this one you go yeah okay this one works
like that that'll do that'll do
i mean well yeah it's just kind of like
you know it's not like filet mignon but
sometimes you just want like a like a
cheap burger on the grill you know what
i mean it's like that
now
and yeah and the real aspect ratio yeah
it looks so much better it's a lot
that's see i'm looking at it and i know
it doesn't quite look right it looks
cheap
but in the original aspect ratio it
probably looked a lot better it did well
because there were a couple scenes too
and i guess i didn't
i noticed it while i was watching it but
it didn't occur to me that it would have
to do with the aspect ratio there were a
couple scenes too not even during action
scenes like during like character
dialogue and stuff where it was framed
really strangely like the top of
someone's head was cut off or like this
person was talking they weren't all the
way in the shot so i so it was that
because like when it first started i was
like why is this like in tv aspect yeah
because you see the
the sets are there the costumes are
there
[ __ ] happens in it that's cool
the monster is cool looking that robot
looks absolutely cool i really like that
monster bunch of cool [ __ ] happens in it
but it doesn't quite look right yeah it
doesn't look good that's why and that's
the aspect right that's what because
they didn't do whenever they did this
version of it in the square aspect ratio
because normally what they i'm not sure
entirely how it works but when usually
they'll if they cut down a movie like
for tv back in the old days where they
had to make it square they would usually
try to do panda scan where they would
try to like frame it so like all the
relevant [ __ ] was still in the frame
but it looks like nobody did that to
this one they just kind of like just
chopped off either ends right and didn't
worry about like centering
the the action or centering the people
in the frame it looks like that yeah i
just thought it was just trying to be
artistic but it was cheap but okay yeah
i gotta and it wasn't so much the
filmmaker because that wasn't like i
said not only did they release did they
chop oh and there was also like a little
bit more at the end too because that was
one thing i thought the movie ended like
really abruptly
there was like a little bit more like at
the end that they cut out for whatever
reason well i think they had to cut it
out because it had it related back to
the subplot about her daughter okay and
they took that subplot out so then they
had to take out the stuff in the in the
end
but i mean i don't know like like i said
it's like so so 90s like the hacker
people what happens in it essentially
like i said it's kind of like
i guess it's kind of like robocop or
something like that there's like a big
faceless evil corporation and they've
been doing this it's a weapons
corporation right yes
ocp it's called uh chank chank yeah
with two a's
shank
um yeah so
they have started like some covert
uh weapon system is i think one's called
like the hard man yeah yeah the hard man
program that's good where it's
essentially they're making like super
soldiers is what they're doing like
they're taking or they're making like
robocops yeah they put you in this damn
foam [ __ ] robocop suits black
yeah
and then they uh access to your mind and
they download a super soldier program
into your in and you become this super
soldier
you you i think forget who you are yeah
they wipe your memory well they they
back it up like on a disc so they have
to put they have to put it back in there
to like put you back in your yes then
you run around like a chode [ __ ]
giving orders to people yelling and
fighting
being brave when you're not brave and
[ __ ] you know it's just
and then uh when you when you're done
they [ __ ] take that chip out and then
put your original [ __ ] chip in there
and [ __ ] then your personality goes
back into it
and the suit is [ __ ] dumb it looks
like uh
well it's it's dumb in the way like the
prototype in robocop remember you know
all the prototype robocops the ones that
pulled their heads off and [ __ ] it was
like that they looked like something
like that
it was kind of a cool idea it wasn't
supposed to be cool because it didn't
work it didn't work well yeah that was
like yeah in the universe of the movie
uh the the program wasn't working and
they were gonna abandon it they only
ended up using the suit at the end to
like to fight against the robot because
they had a choice
them that was like all they had because
otherwise they were going to get the
chomped by the thing but yeah so it's
this company and then they bring in a
new ceo
um
and i guess like some stuff is leaked to
the media about this horrible [ __ ] that
this company's been doing that killed
ended up killing all these children and
there was another thing too like at the
very beginning this starts out with
one of the hard man like super soldiers
i guess he's like glitched out and he
killed a bunch of people in a diner
right
um at the beginning of the movie they
kind of start like in the aftermath of
that but i guess in the original cut it
actually showed more of that so it like
explained it zach says the original and
the proper aspect ratio is on youtube
but it's only a 480. oh is it okay okay
somebody might have uploaded because
like i said
i think that the only country where you
can legally get it is germany but it's
not in english obviously it's in german
uh but
that's i and i don't know if that's
where that guy got the clips from
but in in the correct aspect and i might
be wrong because that video might be old
but yeah so
so there was more uh with the diner
scene at the beginning where they were
kind of establishing that oh the hard
man program's not working like the
people are glitching out and they're
just like murdering random ass people so
there was more of that it was gorier
um and then like so they get in trouble
they bring in this new ceo
uh and she's basically like yeah i'm
gonna clean [ __ ] house what the [ __ ]
are you guys doing in here and she finds
out that this guy
uh brad dorf's character
his uh name is jack dante he works down
in this basement
this basement lab thing
that's just like it looks like a 90s
uh it's got like spray paint like he
spray painted his name on the door and
like keep out like it's very like 90s
teenager kind of thing even though he's
like an adult and it's all kind of like
covered with porn like on the inside
and uh cartoons important he's always
watching that so he's apparently like
built this death machine thing which he
keeps in a vault and he's the only one
like he's a hacker too so he's the only
one that has access to it and she finds
out about it and she's just kind of like
okay well we can't have this because you
know who the [ __ ] knows what else this
crazy person's out here and so but he is
kind of like
but he's not in love with her but he's
like obsessed with her he's like
stalking her like i said he's trying to
rape her at one point but they they cut
that out of the movie but i saw that was
in there but yeah i'm looking at the one
that's on youtube but it doesn't look
that bad yeah it looks pretty good
oh okay there we go
yeah i mean it's a little fuzzy but it
looks like a million dollars
a lot aspect ratios look how much better
that looks then yeah than the square one
yeah and it's two hours and two minutes
oh so that's the uncut one it's the
uncut yeah because the one we saw we
watched the one on voodoo and it was
only an hour and thirty nights see if
it's in english see if it's in english
it is in english
[ __ ] man somebody ripped that all right
well that's cool you can watch it on
youtube then if i hadn't known that we'd
watched it on there yeah like we didn't
pay to watch it
we watched it on voodoo but i didn't
realize until after like we started
doing the um the research for it that
there was that much taken out of it so
that's the uncut version yeah uncut
version that's the two hour one yeah
it's on there free and right next to it
is the cut version that they want to
charge it uh two dollars for three
dollars for
yeah it's crazy it's crazy but yeah so
that so yeah yeah if you're gonna watch
it then go watch it over there like
before they take it down because i
didn't if i hadn't known that then i
would have obviously just watched this
version yeah because but i didn't know
that that much taken out you got the
shitty experience though
yeah and like yeah and that was like
something to talk about yes and i still
enjoyed the movie even though
you know like i said i didn't really
notice most of the time other than in
the action sequences in a couple of the
dialogue scenes that was really the only
time that i noticed like the aspect
ratio thing most of the time i wasn't
really like uh aware of it so it didn't
really like i don't know it didn't
really bother me all that much but you
can see that the scenes the the the the
the sets and the uh the costumes and
special effects it's there
you know it looks pretty good that
aspect ratio is [ __ ] up but
it looks like something from the
late 80s
mid 90s which is what it was yeah 94
yeah even though it's supposed to be set
in 2003 at least according to wikipedia
but that doesn't matter oh another thing
here's another thing that i didn't
notice because remember how he said that
um a lot of the characters in this are
named after you know like uh directors
and stuff
did you notice the one scene
where uh
the guy whose character name is sam
raimi
when he shoots the
rocket like out of his thing they do
like a sam raimi shot like where they
have the rocket going like that like
going like that yeah yeah and i was just
kind of like oh that's clever i see what
you did there yeah so there was actually
like a lot of thought put into this what
i liked is yutani [ __ ] did this epic
battle against the damn robot and turned
around to run and [ __ ] hit his head
on the dam
knocked himself out and then the robot
got him didn't expect that to happen
that was great that was great actually
well actually when i was watching the
good bad flicks one he had that happen
like he did that and then he went
da da
right that's not for prices right it's
from that other game show but yeah like
that failure that failures down
and i was like yeah all happy and [ __ ]
[ __ ] knocked out just
looking at the robot coming to kill him
and he's just like oh well oh well
that's what happens but yeah so those
people they're kind of like they come
into the building later because they're
gonna blow it up and um
so then they end up like having getting
on the wrong end of the of the robot and
they have to like try to get out of the
building and stuff but yutani has
the craziest
hair makeup combination
it's so 90s like i said it's like well
because he has like the red he's playing
well it's not even bald he had like he
the red paint is like that like in his
eye and then like that but then he also
has little shaved
parts in his hair oh okay like which
matches up with where the red goes so
it's almost kind of like shaved
shave-shaped and then it's red i didn't
notice red paint yeah i noticed that
because i was like wow that took a lot
of forethought and well every time they
have that because i feel like they did
that a lot in the 80s and 90s like they
would have these gang members or hackers
or whatever and they always had like
this crazy makeup and hair and i was
like you know that that person had to
get up and like spend two or three hours
doing that in the morning like would
they really because to me it seemed like
the guys that were
uh that went in there to like blow the
place up yeah they just seemed like a
bunch of potheads i mean that was kind
of like a gag early on where it's like
hey i went and got some weed and then
like he's like oh i already got weed and
it's like this ridiculous joint with
like all these other joints like coming
out of it and this joint that looks like
this big around like a [ __ ] burrito
and it's like that it was like yeah they
always steal
punk rockers being like the thugs and
[ __ ] [ __ ] like even in terminal yeah
i was i was watching it it was funny
because they were always like
well-dressed and wearing them uh of
again complicated makeup schemes that
you only wore at clubs it took for
forever to put on yeah even terminator
one
what's his name the guy that played uh
in uh
[ __ ] what was that guy's name
he's sitting there and he's got a damn
tire tread a blue tire tread painted on
his face it would take forever well i
imagine you could probably take a
[ __ ] if you had a tempo template or a
like a sponge that was shaped like that
yeah because a lot of that stuff you
know to get leopard spots in your head
it was just a thin piece of sponge that
you've curled over to make a c
and you just hit it with the dye like
that your girlfriend did it yeah spots
and seas
and you'd uh you could have leopard
leopard print hair
but it's a lot of effort it's a lot of
effort yeah so it's every time i see a
movie they don't really do that so much
anymore i guess but like in the 80s and
the 90s and it's funny because i was
watching this one i can't remember what
her name is but she has like a whole
she's a little bit younger than us i
think she was born in 79 so she's like
seven years younger but she talks a lot
about 80s and 90s goth yeah and uh she
was ma she mentioned that too that like
in the 80s like it seemed like a lot of
bad guys and a lot of big movies were
always punk rockers and i'm just kind of
like and in real life that didn't
usually happen
and it's just kind of like uh you know
so
but that kind of struck me about this
one particular guy i'm like you guys are
just like sitting around in this trailer
like smoking weed it's like there's no
way that dude like meticulously went in
there and drew like because i'm like do
you know how long that would take like
without [ __ ] it up and then like
having the hair
that like went along with it like with
the stripes and everything i'm like you
know it looks like kind of cool but
stupid at the same time yeah punk
rockers were 130 pound teenagers mostly
yeah maybe 115 pounds skinny
guys they weren't about any trouble the
last thing they wanted to do is get into
a fist fight
well i mean usually they were on the
receiving end of trouble we they weren't
the ones that were out there like
picking on people they were usually the
ones getting picked on
i mean 99 times out of a hundred yeah so
it's just like it was always very funny
to me that like they don't know where
you live they always showed that like
these gangs of like punk rockers and
they were just like all these [ __ ]
jerks and bullies and stuff and i'm like
that's not usually how that went the one
the one the ones that me and granthurst
high school i mean we we kind of hung
out with them and nobody messed with
them
nobody messed with them yeah yeah they
had cute girls a lot of cute punk rock
girls
all right so uh are we done talking
about definitely all right so yeah so
if you want to watch this movie
if you like split second you'll probably
like this one as well like i said the
the robot is cool don't watch the
version on vudu because it has 20
minutes taken out and it's all [ __ ] up
the aspect ratio i'd watch it go watch
it free on youtube because that looks a
zillion times better uh and then so you
can get like more of a print now we have
to watch it again yeah
we can watch it again later all right so
uh
it's tuesday right yeah yeah so tomorrow
night is going to be our regular show
and we're going back to the true crime
so we haven't done any true crime for a
while now that i'm thinking about it so
we're going to because remember a long
time ago when we did like the fast food
massacre show and i didn't get around to
two of the cases that i want to talk
about like the burger chef murders and
the austin yogurt shop yogurt shop so
we're gonna talk about those two uh
tomorrow night which uh that should be
well i don't know fun is the right word
but you know
so everybody drop by uh tomorrow at 6
p.m and we'll do some true crime and uh
we'll see you again later on